i still wonder
what kind of man it takes what kind of
human being it takes to do that
because i've been studying vladimir
putin quite a bit
right and he's still i believe
he still has popular support that that's
not
fully manipulated because i know a lot
of people in russia
and actually almost the entirety of my
family in russia
are big supporters of putin and
everybody i talk
to sort of that's not just like on
social media
right like the people that live in
russia seems to
seem to support him it feels like
this will be in a george washington
way now would be the time that
would putin just like yeltsin could
relinquish power
and thereby in the eyes of russians
become in in like the long arc of
history
be viewed as a great leader you look at
the economic growth of russia
you look at the rescue from the collapse
of the soviet union and russia finding
its footing
and then relinquishing power in a way
that
that perhaps if russia succeeds forms a
truly democratic state
this would be how putin can become one
of the great leaders in russian history
uh at least in the in the context of the
21st century
i think there are two reasons why this
is really hard
for putin and for others one is the
trappings of power
are very seductive as you said before
they're corrupting this is a real
problem
right if it's in the business context
you don't want to give up that private
jet
uh if it's in putin's context it's
billions of dollars every year that he's
able to
take for himself or give to his friends
it's not that he'll be poor if he leaves
he'll still be rich
and he has billions of dollars stored
away but he won't be able to get the new
billions
and so that's part of the trappings of
power are a big deal
and then second in putin's case in
particular he has to be worried about
what happens next
will he be tried will someone you know
try to come and arrest him will someone
try to come and assassinate him
washington recognized that leaving early
limited the corruption and limited the
enemies that you made
and so it was a strategic choice putin
has at this point been in power too long
and
this comes back to your core insight
it's a cliche but it's true power
corrupts
no one should have power for too long
this was one of the best insights the
founders of the united states had
that power was to be held for a short
time as a fiduciary responsibility
not as something you owned right this is
the problem with monarchy with
aristocracy that you
own power right we don't own power we
we're
holding it in trust yeah there's uh
there's some probably like very specific
psychological study
of uh how many years it takes for you to
forget
that you can't own power that's right
there's you know
that's could be a much more rigorous
discussion about the length of terms
that are appropriate but really
there's an amount like stalin had power
for 30 years like putin is pushing
those that many years already
there's a certain point where you forget
the person you were before you took the
power
that's right you forget to be humble in
the face of this responsibility
and then there's no going back that's
right that's how dictators are born
that's how the evil like authoritarians
become
evil or let's not use the word evil but
uh counterproductive destructive to the
to the ideal that they initially
probably came to office with that's
right
you